just give everyone about their who may
not know just a brief background on who
you are my name is Lincoln o berry and
pretty much my whole life I've worked
with my dad we have an organization
called dolphin projects and basically
our mandate is for the welfare and
protection of dolphins worldwide and we
primarily deal with dolphins with the
captivity issue and also dolphins that
are being slaughtered in that issue so
how did you get I mean obviously your
dad is like a super famous figure in
this in this world and you know he's you
guys have been a part of movies like The
Cove how did he bring you into this
whole world I just got brought into it
because it was you know in the house
when the phone rang it was usually
somebody calling for the dolphin project
and so I just you know I was looking
just got you sanction the phone like
dolphin project and yeah well it was
just what I knew like you know we had
like when I was a little kid we had a
facility with dolphins when I was like
you know a baby and so I grew up just
having dolphins right there basically at
the house and stuff come you know he for
those don't know how he got his start
Ric O'Barry my dad kid he was initially
the trainer at the - aquarium which at
the time was like the second or third
dolphinarium in the entire country it
was located in Miami and this was the
very early 1960s and basically he got
out of the Navy got a job at Seaquarium
I think his first job was working on
their collection boat and that was the
boat that would go out and get all the
animals that would go to the reef and
they'd get fish and they get turtles and
they catch dolphins as well and a lot of
more cotton here or in Miami the
original dolphins at this aquarium and
then flipper came along and just - a
chance meeting one day at the Seaquarium
my dad met Rico browning who was the
director and kind of creator of flipper
and at that time they were just shooting
the initial pilot which was actually a
movie and Rico was the trainer on that
the movie and then it was very popular
and got picked up as a TV show and so
they decided to use the back lot of
Seaquarium to do the series and my dad
had met Rico and so my dad became the
head trainer Rico wanted to be the
director and so he directed all the
episodes of my dad was the trainer and
so they actually went and caught five
dolphins that we're gonna play flipper
because you have to have multiple
dolphins in case one doesn't want to
work or some or better at some tricks
and others yeah so my dad helped a year
or two before the show even started
shooting helped catch the Dolphins they
were in a back part of the - aquarium
and then trained the Dolphins and then
basically you know they would shoot all
the exterior shots with the Dolphins all
at one time for all the episodes so they
would come for like a month or five
weeks and shoot all those shots and then
everything else was done in sound stages
and other locations and so then my dad
was basically left alone for most of the
year with the dolphins and so he lived
there right when you see the flipper TV
show like we're Ranger Rick and his
family lived like that's where my dad
lived and he had the dock right there
and he would sometimes take the TV set
with a long extension cord and put it
out on the dock and like watch flipper
with flipper the dolphins and like he
lived there with him and he was employed
by the TV show and this aquarium at the
same time so he was like the
highest-paid person at the Seaquarium
and was driving a sports car and you
know then with the popularity flipper a
flipper the TV series took off like a
rocket so now everyone wants to hug a
dolphin kiss it off and see a dolphin
so now Miami Seaquarium where he works
started catching dolphins and selling
him I think it was like a female dolphin
was like 350 bucks and a male dolphin
would be $250 and you could literally
pull up in your station wagon to this
aquarium and for 300 bucks they've
loaded off and in your car and you could
drive off and they didn't know if it was
going to someone's house or going to an
aquarium or where it was going and so
you saw a proliferation all sudden of
dolphinariums they were popping up
everywhere with with the popularity of
flipper and so eventually the flipper
series ended and those dolphins were
partially owned by the TV show and
Seaquarium and they were actually just
warehoused in the back they weren't used
for shows after that and my dad after
needed a feed some time off and he
just kind of hanging out he gets a phone
call one day that his favorite dolphin
named Kathy there were five dolphins
that played flipper but one he
identified with the most and spent the
most time with he got a call that she
was near death so he went since Aquarium
and she literally swam into his arms and
died and he just at that moment kind of
had this moment of Epiphany like what
have I done
like I'm the guy that trained flipper
that made dolphins popular and now
they're popular now they're
dolphinariums everywhere and I helped
catch a lot of those dolphins and this
was in 1970 approximately right around
now it was like beginning of it April
end of March is when the flipper died
and so he just kind of didn't know what
to do and so on Earth Day 1970 which is
50 years we're selling that anniversary
this month on the 22nd my dad flew to
Bimini where they had sold somebody
there three or three or four dolphins it
was called the Lerner Marine Laboratory
it was owned by a family that owned a
chain of shopping stores called lerner
and they had they had their own lab that
they create is basically their pet
dolphins but they had like kind of like
other animals and cages and you could
see them and they said they were doing
research but it was really a family
thing anyhow all the Dolphins had died
there was only one left named Charlie
Brown so on Earth Day 1970 my dad flew
to Bimini wearing a green armband in
symbolic for Earth Day and he went that
night of Earth Day and cut the pen to
let Charlie Brown go and the pen fell
away and the dolphin was swimming around
he wouldn't leave and so my dad got in
the pen he's trying to chase the dolphin
out it wouldn't leave and finally he
hadn't ran my dad had rented a little
rubber 12-foot rubber boat with a motor
to get out to the sea pen and it was
very high tide and so he was able to get
the boat into the pen and was trying to
chase the dolphin out and for hours and
the doleful wouldn't leave and
eventually the tide dropped and now the
boat is stock inside of the pen that he
rented so it's going to come back to him
so he just
his green armband on he walked down to
the office of the lunar Marine Lab
knocked on the door and basically told
him like last night I tried to let your
dolphin go so they arrested him and it
was like front page of the Miami Herald
flippers trainer in a flap and there's
the picture of him being led into jail
wearing his Miami Seaquarium t-shirt he
had Seaquarium t-shirt on he spent like
four or five days in jail and then the
judge let him out and give him a five
dollar fine and threw him out of the
country and about two weeks after that
my dad was in Miami just milling about
what do I want to do like what's going
on with my life like you know what would
and he actually went sailing with he was
best friends at the times of the guy
named Fred Neill who was a very famous
folk singer he wrote the theme song to
Midnight Cowboy
everybody's talking that was a song but
he's got many others and he was kind of
the Godfather the folk music scene and
many other musicians hung around this
guy and so Fred that day was going
sailing with stephen stills from crosby
Stills and Nash and showed up at my
dad's house knew my dad was depressed
and said come on come on the boat and so
my dad's out sailing in the bay with
them and they're talking about no my dad
just told him what happened and he quit
his job and he just got arrested and
he's like I think I want to do this I
want to let dolphins go I want to tear
down what I've just built this monster
that I created this dolphinarium
industry your hands Stephen Stills and
Fred Neal alone I think
wrote it right there wrote him a check
there like long as what you do is legal
were behind you and they wrote him a
check for like five grand and with that
money my dad went and printed some
dolphin project t-shirts and then he
identified a dolphin and the keys
there's a place called dolphin research
center in the keys it was called I think
was called flipper sea school back then
and it was a place where you code paid
us from with the dolphins and a guy
named Hugh Downs he was a famous
broadcaster he used to host twenty20
back in the day when twenty20 was like
60 minutes it was a respectable like
news show
she owned this dolphin it was against
pet dolphin and he left he would live
that this facility where they took care
of it and whenever he was in the keys he
visited it was kind of like bubbles the
chimp with Michael Jackson like you know
the chimp wasn't at Michael's house all
the time it was like once in a while
he'd go visit it wherever it was or but
so my dad convinced Hugh Downs to let
him have the dolphin and that they
wanted to release it back in the wild so
my mom and dad who weren't married they
were just dating at the time went down
to the keys set up a tent and had a
dolphin project logo that we still opted
this day on on the tent and lived there
with the dolphins and we eventually
moved them up to Coconut Grove where we
where I am now Key Biscayne and we set
up a facility there where we had the
dolphins for a couple years and then
eventually rented a a seaplane put the
dolphins in and flew them to the Bahamas
Wow 1974 I think 74 75 and just flew
around till we saw wild dolphins and
landed the seaplane and let them go and
that was the first like release of
dolphins that the dolphin project did
and Wow
and so we basically had that mandate my
dad basically just spent the past 50
years of his life 50 years on April 22nd
[Music]
released it you know we're trying to
tear down this industry that he create
and no you know there's been a lot of
like whistleblower black fish had a
bunch of whistleblower trainers because
my dad has that experience of being in
the industry to be able to speak about
it but his view history is just so
unique because he was just there at the
birth of the movement and he comes you
know it's not his fault what happened
but he can he was in that position where
he was part of what named dolphins
popular and then also catching them and
so he really felt responsible for it and
so he's just I think the guilt is kind
of like let him his whole life
[Laughter]